[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to be talking about peace
technology we have jinx at new joining
us on the show thank you thank you so
much for coming on [ __ ] show I'm very
excited to talk about especially your
new book peace tech thank you thank you
and for those who don't know jinx is
background jinx is a journalist and an
author you can find jinx just links
below junction neucom as well as the
amazon book link should you check those
out
ok J so let's start with understanding
who you are where you were born you're
born in shengshou in the Henan Province
in China grew up in a city about two
hours outside of there you were telling
me that you guys make all your food and
make all your clothes also cool stuff so
teach us about where you're born yes so
it is a very remote mountain area where
I grow up with but you know it's so
beautiful and people there live very
simple very simple even very hard you
know how to work in life but very happy
so we do have a lot of you know
activities just in the nature and I
think that's why when I after I grew up
I was keep looking for the same thing
you know it's just a harmony with nature
and with people surrounded you and
that's what I have when I grow up and
I'm just I just think it's great and
everyone should have that and I think
it's also related to you know later I'm
writing book and later I become Buddhist
so the same thing in my heart so I want
to have that and want to share that can
the same simple but happy life yes yes
and this is so important when we look at
immersion into nature and living in a
home
with our planet is one of the most
important things in each other in
harmony with each other for for being
able to have peace on this planet
together and it makes total sense that
you ended up picking up the Buddhism as
well growing up in nature so what was it
like then did you end up partaking a lot
in the grow and growing food and making
clothes yourself too or what was it like
with your with the fellow people that
you grew up with
everyone is just farmers you know
because you have to you have you have to
leave on your own hands so the first
thing is you plant all the vegetables
all the wheat cones and all the fruits
vegetables everything you need and then
you know afters after this after you
feed your whole family if you have other
time then you can maybe do some extra
work like you know you can be you can do
some dancing music right but primary
thing is everyone's peasant and happy
parents so in my childhood
what I do my playing around is is a
creek is a mountain I'm a hiking I pick
flowers I choose the beautiful stones in
the river I try to catch fishes you know
it's Reyes that's all the my choice and
all my pleasure so it is very difficult
in in a way that even as a child I have
to work in the view indicated if someone
is planting the food they have to spend
time farming the food every day making
sure that it's growing well and then you
can go do everything else but here
everything is in supermarket yes here
yes that's a thing when when I get all
told my mountain and I realize that
people in the cities they know nothing
about where the food come from
where their vegetable where the fruit
come from and they just you know they
ask them they they will say this email
says it come from Safeway so yeah yeah
yeah goda going to farmers markets it's
very nice because then you can at least
in ask the question where is your farm
connect in a different way but actually
going and planting the food and and so
that's interesting that you had that and
then playing in the creek as well
connecting in nature these types of
activities is so important for
development of your of your spirit
really in the world and I'm glad you had
that growing up and then how about
picking up your interests in in
journalism and writing how did you pick
those up when you were younger
well I was always very into writing when
I was very young but I think one
important factor is you know when you
grow up
in in the nature that nature it yourself
nature mother itself it gives you lots
of inspirations the beauty itself
because sometimes you look at the sunset
a mountains there it is a poem itself
and sometime you know you feel you if
you felt like there's so many stories
behind all these things and you heard
these legends stories from from my
grandma from neighbors so these stories
and on all this beauty this is keep me
keep writing I just I just try to keep
writing all the time and then one winter
university I was like wow there's a
major called journalism you can
literally living by writing and by you
know traveling to talking to people I
think it's fascinating so yeah that's
why then I of course I graduated master
of journalism and communication and then
I become journalists in a journalist and
keep working and then I keep and start
writing books you know it's just writing
is what I've been doing all my life and
then this is so beautiful you said that
even the Sun and
moon in the horizon and sunsets sunrises
all these things flowers going from the
ground trees they're poles the they are
and you know that every time you pass by
even the same view even they didn't see
anything
the mountain itself the river it
yourself it's feel like an old friend it
feels like it won't tell you something
yes so you just you know it just
naturally blend into the inspiration
nature gives you yes yes see it seems
like a young person growing up in a
metropolis in the heart of the city it
doesn't have access to the same the same
because of light pollution you don't get
to see the stars because you don't grow
food you don't get you don't get a play
in the creek or learn how to talk to
learn from the mountain or see the Sun
all these types of things so it's a big
disconnection from where we come from
from nature yes yes that's actually I
think it's really a pity it's really
Nora T's you know kids grow up in the
city they grow up with Kindle and you
know computers and TV sad it's they were
really the they forget that to connect
you with nature it's it's part of who we
are yes in a lot of why we have so many
of the issues in our world is because we
lost that connection to nature okay and
then so it was some it was an nanjing
Normal University it was where you did
the journalism communication and then
senior journalism for about six years or
so in China now what is it like being a
journal topics where you cover were you
covering in China a melon covering
business and technology sometimes a
financial that you know it's all related
so what I'm where I'm working Georgian
province it's a very unique Province in
China I can say
it's our richest province in china the
intrapreneurs the stops there they're
very active so and I do learned a lot
from them and I felt some very inspiring
and they're also very hard-working
the famous one like Jack Myers won one
of the judge entrepreneur so and so
you're writing a lot about the tech and
entrepreneurship financed seen this type
stuff and then maybe give us some of the
like ideas it was it's kind of similar
to in terms of like Silicon Valley like
in terms of tech advancements is it kind
of similar that people were kind of
making software and hardware and trying
to make things more smooth um that's a
difference so in China manufacturing is
to do a big thing so what I am what what
I'm working on is you know there's of
course you're still like software
hardware and advanced technology of
course China is catching up very you
know very very rapidly but the tradition
of manufacturing is to one pillow
industry and like we called smart
factories technologies we call smart
factory but before all the Internet of
Things and crowd communicating before
all these technologies they're just
factories you know so there's lots of
lots of entrepreneurs they're still
working on traditional factories but
when this technology all these technical
income would they're challenging is they
have to pick up quickly they have to use
them quickly otherwise it going to be
lag behind so that's a big difference I
think compared with a second Veda in
tech okay
and then what was it then that brought
you then to going coming to the United
States and wanting to write your first
book yeah so it's also related to you
know I think from 2014 and 2015 the
intrapreneurs in China especially in
judge on province they were just so
eager to learn that's the year when big
dater when when crowd computing when
Internet of Things when all and when I I
you know later blocked when all these
technologies suddenly you know is just
overwhelming and every day I confuse and
theater of the Chinese entrepreneurs
they were like if I don't study today
I'm going to die tomorrow so they put a
lot of effort in studying this
technology they want to figure out what
it is how it's going to relate it to my
future
so I mean involved a lot in reporting
such kind of you know use new technology
to improve our industry this kind of
topic and of course the most important
question is everyone trying to try to
figure out what is happening exactly
with all the technology what what where
it come from and where it's going to be
so with all with these two main
questions and when I start collaboration
with Karros Goffe he's you know his
author of history of Silicon Valley and
his cultural historian but he's also
here he also has a very good insight of
technology that's why in 2016 and we
start our first collaboration in human
can to ponder a book I'll talk about the
trends of technologies that's this is so
interesting that when you take all these
different fields like the Internet of
Things and cloud
shooting blockchain AI that when you
take them and then you say that there
are people that are watching that
explosion of technology happening and
then they say okay if I don't study this
stuff big date if I don't study this
stuff I'm gonna get left behind
yes so I have to study this stuff yes I
have to know how it's applying to our
world today how it's going to apply to
our world - to the kids all this type of
stuff and so write about it and then to
explain that you know humans really are
gonna be much different like you were
telling me like half human half robot
future and so this sort of writing about
the us being reshaped by the emergence
of all this technology I think that's a
very powerful first YA book thank you
yes yes that's many with what we're
talking about you know in human can 2.0
and actually that will also lead to why
I start writing this this technology
book yes this just released yes it's
just released this year one months ago
so after collaboration with Paris coffee
finished the first book human can chew
bone zero I realized one big question is
I was here interviewed Silicon Valley
experts intrapreneurs scholars for two
months so every time I asked them in the
end always once in question what if this
technology is used like say not properly
a weapon nice yes you know and who is
going to be responsible for that you
know wherever the people tell me how
powerful it is the Bell tag you know
like gene editing AI like when I ask the
same question to this to these stinkers
experts they tend to give me a same
answer like technology is just a tool
everyone says that same thing yeah I
went to MIT
just to it depends on how you're going
to use it and that's it and if you are
good people you can use a hammer to like
say you can view the furniture if you
are bad people you can use a hammer to
kill someone and that's not what we can
control but so I just not happy with
this answer likewise yeah and you are
basically the the people I interviewed
all I can says there are the smartest
people with group of smartest people in
this world in this you know biotech AI
they're all big names and so you are
telling me this literally nothing we can
do and with all these powerful even
scary technology so I'm not happy with
that and now I want to explore like more
answers right and then that's where I
find peace Innovation Lab at Stanford
and what they are doing is actually
they're trying to find in a way they
chew to try and find the answer the you
can tell from the name peace
intermission so they were trying to say
in Silicon Valley technology can solve
sins can solve all the problem but you
know in terms of create a peaceful
society a peaceful world a better world
whatever exactly we can use technology
for so that's why it's least this as to
clear Annihilus to this book we start
collaboration with peace innovation app
others have been the same thing since
I've been here I've been asking the same
questions and it's so why is that the
main answer I think it's because it gets
people to get you away from them fastest
just a tool it can be used either good
or bad
I know it's pure like standard answer
yes and I think it's it's really
difficult because you know actually I
love one scientist he she she gave me
she gave me our different answers she
said you know what why you asked me I'm
a scientist I know how to develop this
technology but how to use it don't you
think you should ask the you know
everyone know who you know do you think
should like it's you guys are using it
I'm I'm not the one can tell you that
principles and morality you know oh my
gosh we need yeah philosophers and moral
scientists thinkers yeah we need them
involved ethicists involved as soon as
possible yeah exactly so after she gave
me that answer I think she's right you
know why we give why we put all the
pressure on scientists like sons to have
to answer all the questions it's not
player but it is true that the
philosophy is that everyone you and him
and the kids in high school everyone who
are using technology should be
responsible and also the question should
be involved in this question so and
tonight it's very true to answer this
question it becomes are like
interdiscipline project it has to be
yeah yeah this is probably one of the
most important things that we can start
doing is having young people start
thinking about the complex philosophies
and morality and ethics around the
exponential technologies and then also
to get those people those people in
those fields philosopher assigned to
that assist moral scientists involved in
AI creation
the blockchain development and biotech
it's all these fields as soon as
possible I I'm happy that that's the you
know you're driven to write this let's
also explain how we need this is this is
kind of what we're talking about with
this technology for preventing and
reducing conflict for increasing
positive engagement between individuals
groups and nations yes so let's let's
start unpacking some of the ways that we
can let's define let's define peace yes
so normally when we say peace we
actually only mean we don't have a wall
you know
so this candle piece in academia there
there's academic term called negative
peace it's like I have peace with table
I have peace with him with that wall
there's no wars it's no conflict but
that's it and there's obviously there's
there's a different relationship like
between you and me we are not just no
conflict we are friends we are you know
we can collaborate to do lots of things
so in this candle piece obvious it's
more interesting and more variable so so
we this candle piece it's kind of like
positive engagement so we call it
positive peace yes yeah so this is this
this definitional piece is not like a
novel idea you know each words each were
there decades ago
it's just now when we look at in look at
into this definition we realize now it's
a it's a word of technology and in terms
of working on peace there there is
potentially a lot of new tools new mess
Messer's you know lots of things to
explore yeah I really like this
definition because it almost seems like
the above what we hear about pieces like
you said just oh there's not war so it's
kind of like neutral state of oh yeah
they're over there they do their thing
there's just ya know conflict and stuff
but positive peace is hey I know you're
there
I have you know deep love and desire to
collaborate and we can explore
collaboration I think that's so
beautifully said that if we can stretch
ourselves to like positive peace
worldwide I think that's extremely
powerful and then also there is that
doesn't mean no competition because
competition is still good for getting
ideas out there and all these types of
things so but positive ideas positive
collaboration positive peace I like that
a lot
and then what about then measuring peace
and the stories of specific applications
of peace technology how would we be able
to measure it
yeah so about peace technology about
this term there's there's a few signals
as to want to say you know this term
actually I think it come it came out
like 2015 there's there's one important
principle I love a lot is when we talk
about peace technology what we are
discussing is not about these
technologies is palpable it's good or
not good or bad or who should control it
China should accentuate us you can show
it it's not about all these this
technology fundamental thing about it is
it is something we should technology
something we should collaborate together
to develop it to use it to get other
people to use it make sure this to this
technology can benefit all of us so this
this pretty simple I want to emphasize
because you know that
point Oh piss technology and so because
peace has you know negativities and
positive peace so peace technology
naturally has two cans applications why
is you used technology to reduce
conflict
mmm oh you know we reduce or minimize
war or completes and/or prevent you know
you know you give early early alarms or
complex these all around this so an
example of like a negative peace
technology could be something like
developing military weaponry to observe
other countries development of weaponry
and this is tough stuff like that is
that potential yeah it is already lot of
these piece technology in working on you
know reduce prevent conflict for example
there's us a key it's a united states of
peace
so the it was established 1984 I believe
so they were working on this area long
time has a long history in 2015 they
they establish a lab called piece check
lab so this like for example they have
the this monster
they helped I'm not sure how much this
man helped stop from Indian what they do
is very simple they the three girls a
Indian the developer app in for the
people in for the woman living in you
know that the terrible neighborhood like
slum you know it's very simple whenever
you sense danger you can immediately
click the app and they will say it will
send your your your location your
message you know like
the thing you can set at the best to all
your friends and families yes you need
help yes you need it this is very very
simple
pardis technology yes but it is this
technology cause you are working on
prevent and reduce a complete okay yes
okay okay I see I see and that's that's
a really good example right that's a
good example of yeah yeah
but then the other one it seems like one
that sometimes governments around the
world kind of justify their military
developments because oh there's so many
threats around the world and like there
are actually yes some threats and so
there is some seems like there's some
justification but it feels like if we
did what we talked about the beginning
of just this connection deeper to nature
to source to what what sustains us all
we wouldn't need so many of the yes we
need any of the military conflict yes so
about this I want to give exact another
example so there's there's a nonprofit
organization called peace factory so it
was that it 2012 in the Middle East so
when the war when the war between Iran
and Israel Israel is going to you know
start and so everyone know is going to
be a war and of course everyone's scared
and this Ronnie he just he simply post
he just posts a picture of him he's a
father he's an engineer and he just
simply post he he and his daughters
picture together
and with with the sentence Israel we you
are we love you we will never bump your
country mm-hmm and with this picture and
then on Facebook it's bright very
quickly and in next morning when he
opened the Facebook page he saw like
loud
a lot of forward lots of people crying
people really moved about and very
rapidly people volunteered to post such
pictures to connecting more people
because one key point like you just
mentioned every country has their needs
depends the security when they acclaim a
war they will say we have to do it
because we have to protect our country
but protect our people but in reality is
when you don't have any connections we
you don't even know who is your enemy
you only know from the TV from the news
so what's you what you get is the people
you are going to start a war it's just
someone like crazy you know you never
even have sit-down with a real person
you know you call enemy to have a coffee
or conversation with you so so this
piece factory inspector found the Rani
he he think his shot is a huge problem
then he used Facebook as a tool to
connect the people in the Middle East to
connect Iran's and and Israel's you know
connect people there and encourage
people to have conversation to connect
it and to know each other better to know
that they're not just monsters crazy
people show bombs to you they are also
like everyone else their fathers and
mothers you know yes normal people like
everyone else their kids also like our
kids
you know this smell the want go to
school the same thing so that's that are
another example that you you even
Facebook you know it's such such simple
to and you can use it to change
something yes make difference
I love this example the piece factory
example it can even do things like like
get potentially even prevent war prevent
conflicts if you get enough people it's
such an easy thing to do this is a good
potentially recommendation for those at
homeless to do something like take a
picture of yourself maybe with your
loved one or whoever and take the
picture and write in the caption or
maybe take it with an image of another
country and write hey like I would love
to meet someone from this country for a
coffee or tea and talk to you and get to
know who you are and we'll never harm
you you know yeah stuff like that I love
that that's a real so that that is also
that is also later this Ronnie he reach
it to PC Innovation Lab at a Stanford
and they they were together they were
discussing how we can you know really
use technology to build more connections
and then better communication and then
finally with you the trust we need
cooperation and the beautiful thing is
the moment I know you the moment I
cooperated with you
the chance that I will start a war with
you I cool you is very very low yes
right yes yes versus seeing over the
Internet the fear propaganda yeah I
think yeah never meeting someone from
that place in person yes
hiding the chance of conflict yes so it
is very powerful in the way you don't
you don't see people just as some just
some just a vague some big enemies and
you actually individual them you see
them one by one at just one person yeah
and it
then they will make you really difficult
to say I won't harm I want to just you
know do something terrible to that
person yeah
yes yes and this was also mentioned on
our episode with Tim Draper where he
said that when you see people that are
conflict across countries it's usually
just like presidents or the people that
are running the countries and government
officials and stuff like that conflict
across countries but then he says I have
so many friends in that country and we
have such good friendships in that
country and so that you got to always
remember that you know really feel that
that by making friends in other
countries those are the real ties not
the ones of the governments that are
that's all a lot of that it's just fear
propaganda and so I like this one and I
think that's a really good action item
for people as to I'm gonna do it myself
I'm gonna make a post myself about that
so I hope other people make those posts
and hopefully have them liked and shared
by other people that's a really good one
yes so that's why you know when I was
writing this book that's one important
goal I'll say vision I am expecting from
this book because literally that
technology is something is everywhere
now and if you if you ask a people you
never know who have different religion
to speak the different language right a
stranger if you ask them to do something
a simple thing it should be very
difficult but if you ask them hey at me
facebook friend or you know oh let's
share your car let's use and indeed no
problem people can easily we
these technologies they can actually
connect it and do something together but
without this technology if you try to do
something with very different you know
background it's another story
so the pudding show the beauty of
technology today is it is actually more
powerful than even religions than any
like kings or you know popes in the
history okay so this is also the words
from peace in the vision of the director
Mark Nelson so he was telling me when I
just met him he was telling me like I
was he said I'm so so shocked when I see
in true Sun and that you know people
everyone just using Facebook they
volunteer to a big lot of the personal
details pictures and they don't ask a
payback you know this and every
disability reduce the same thing and he
was shocked he said he said and also in
a later he saw Twitter he's a Whooper
and all these technology companies arise
right this is who in this world can
persuade so many people to do the same
thing ya know a court you know beyond
all your language or country your
religion difference you're doing the
same thing you're speaking the same
language by using the same to Facebook
Google all this you know where are me
the same to so this is very powerful but
we just get used it to the real
important thing is since it's everywhere
and to means everyone has a potential to
use it to do something good with it yeah
and we use that it seems like the
technology being there for free
enhancing our lives was the reason why
we all ran to go sign up for it and give
our way everything because we could
freely enhance our lives just needed
connection
that in a computer yes so let's let's
cover on measuring yes so to marry piece
you know that's a very difficult issue
it's because many because when we define
piece as positive engagement we first
the first thing we need is what we call
data we call piece dieter so because if
you don't know what's the engagement
between us is like like how many times
and meet you in one months how many
times when I meet you did I hug you
did they give you eye contact you know
all these small small engagement it
matters yeah yeah it doesn't matter yeah
if you if you put a bunch of people in
the room it can be a small group it can
be a lot of people then if you observe
carefully how they engage you know
what's what in getting to like it so you
if you have all these dangers and then
you can of course you can do something
so the piece data it's actually there's
already some Pacific application like
Mirror Mirror communication and Tim's
mirror innovation measure marry
cooperation so in this book we also get
lost inspiration from these different
masses from different teams but what's
the unique thing about Mary piece is it
related to so much more bitter than just
a mirror innovation or trust or
corporate cooperation it it means all
this engagement between you and me
between Piero between him all this
engagement has to be married recorded
yes first yes and when you marry this
data there's not just I shake hands with
you I hug with you on all a community
with you on it also one important thing
is
why why I you know I I just shake your
hand I'm not I'm not kissing you right
the relationship between us is different
and the relationship between us is
different is we believe the peace
innovation lab believe it's related to a
lot you group identities the group
identity means like who you are you you
must belong somehow belong to a group
for you belong to who you are you are
you know you are hosts you are you you
know you are a writer you are artists
you know and everyone the way you labor
yourself is one of your group and they
didn't win and and we believe in peace
Innovation Lab there's one concept is
that the also conflicts they are wise is
belief is mostly because that our group
identity when I met you as the knowing
you the first thing I noticed there how
differently I met for example I'm a
Buddhist while you are not a Buddhist
you are like you know you're a weird
religion never heard of when you're so
different on me you know people
sometimes we all know sometimes even you
did nothing wrong
you just belong to a different group
people can already start suspecting you
know like you're not well us you are
wild uh you know when this that look at
the difference the different group
identity between people that's when the
war starts arriving in
and is vs. human first and then then
there's there's something like a peace
index that can almost be measured
between people you can look at people
and see how they react and you know why
are they only shaking hands instead of
hugging like you're indicating earlier
could if they hug and they hug for maybe
like 30 second hug long hug yes maybe
then maybe that means there's a higher
peace index who knows peace rating
measuring peace yeah yes so we do we do
want to mirror you know what a beauty
thing about today's technology is they
do enable us to capture all these
engagement we have all these sensors
cameras everywhere right if you want you
can easily record it spoils ample if you
have a team as you have a stop for 10
even 20 people working together you can
easily record when you have meetings how
everyone engaged how events speaking to
each other right so to record this
teacher is is become feasible and the
scenery behind like what I just said is
that the conflict usually related to
when I see a difference between you and
me I see a different what we call group
updated but on the other hand that also
means if I am able to see more
similarities common things between you
and me and then maybe the relationship
is going to change you can see very
common that when two peoples that know
each other are we from the same time
which we share the like the the same
school or you know the same experience
can suddenly make two people very close
right so the that gives that
technology how we can apply how we can
use technology to help people to find
the more things in common
rather than things like you are just
different you know I love this one this
was so good like you said it you can
approach someone and say oh I'm a
Buddhist well what why are you a
different religion or you can approach
them and say oh like who are you you
know you are another human whatever
things do we have in common instead of
what things do we have different yeah
and then how can you start from there
you know the place of love and
compassion asking questions and learning
that I love that I think that's a good
one in leveraging technology to be able
to do that can you record a meeting can
and see how people interact with each
other this type of stuff but then you
can also maybe nudge like people gently
like if two people are maybe using words
and you can maybe process the natural
language process and see who has
sentiment that's more aggressive or
something like that
exactly maybe you can nudge them towards
peace with technology exactly you know
that's actually when I was disgusting
this piece technology in AI there's for
example there's one beautiful example
when now we can talk to robots right you
can you can always say what's a robots
and Alex hi when you hi X mm-hmm right
Alexa is oh yeah so you know you can try
to talk to them but but sometimes the
answers is not like not good enough when
when you say for example when you say Oh
today a few underpriced I'm sad and you
will see that the robot we immediately
will see I suggest you go to listen some
music or have a walk with friends and
the realities after you heard this you
don't feel better
so mmm and and daddy's thing is if we
can try to miss this AI mix this
technology have more empathy mm-hmm like
the the same concept you are saying we
so the in this book we mentioned that if
we can use there's a communication
communication theory called non balanced
communication so with this communication
theory applied to AI maybe later when
you talk to Robert do you say hey Alex
today a few said and and this robot will
try to feel you know okay I understand
your feeling you know I answer you
different yes and make you feel more
like oh I be understand not just someone
immediately try to say just go to listen
to music you know yeah so this is
another very teacher that also that you
can use AI or use technology to in his
positive engagement even before even
between robots and humans yeah and also
when you are writing you know emails
tell you know test you can also use AI
do the same thing when you write email
you see I really don't like you I you
know whereas the sentence live there's
going to be some combat highlight shows
up Andy are you sure you want to send
this yes so it's the same concept so if
we if we can focus more on you know the
go what's ago or using AI what's cool
about surrounded us everywhere the is a
go to you know to service our human have
a better life
oh you know have a better war if if that
so then we want to apply all these em
per se you know positive engagement even
with robotics so
that's another these are such good
examples Chang should I feel like we're
finally starting to really instead of
just say all technology is just the tool
can be used for good or bad here it's
like no we know how to use it for good
we know how to use it for peace so let's
move it in this direction yes exactly so
for the intrapreneurs for the for the
people who are developing using
technology so they of course they want
to say we don't want to do harm
we don't want be evil but the question
is we also don't know how to be good
like what how can I use my technology to
be good they got confused
what are pretty simple is what's the
guidelines they also don't know so
that's why that's also I think the
research of peace technology matters
because you need to you need to come up
with these guidelines these principles
so tell everyone if you can use
technology this way use your eye eyes
this way with more ampere see you know
if you can use your your choose to to
increase the positive engagement between
people if you can increase in general
people's ability to be good to each each
other then okay you are in a good
direction you can keep going
otherwise maybe you know you should be
more careful you know this is it's also
one one thing that I really looking
forward that you know this book will
make a difference even a slight
difference it's going to yeah it already
has
it already did in my life and it likely
already did for run and it likely
already did for the people that are
viewing this so the butterfly effect and
all the people that are at the Peace
Innovation Lab all the people that you
talk to about this
it makes a big effect it's the butterfly
effect and then we go and we talk about
it
really I urge I urge you all to take a
look at piece tech please this is very
beautiful I'm so happy that we're having
this this conversation and yeah yeah
yeah you're right about on on these are
the technologies that can improve
collaboration that can improve peace and
how we can apply it so what do you then
do you expect then that more people are
going to be more conscious about peace
technology and about moving us in that
direction
yes of course and like I said because
technology is a universal tool it's
literally even teenager can can do
something about it
and if and no matter who you are no
matter what profession you are you know
you you can as long as you are aware
that technology is something impact our
life everyone's life deeply and we don't
want to be too late to do something good
we want to do it now before it's too
late
so I think you know to marry in peace is
the first step and then we can do
something about it right the first type
of later what we can do after we eyes
should finish that after we collect the
data between us between it can be two
people but it accounts council in a
group it can even between cities whether
it even can between countries it depends
on how much detail you have right so the
first step when you collect enough
engagement dangers the second step is
you try to figure out everyone you you
have the ability to do something means
after you have this teacher you can
detect the Pacific problem in your
community in our team in a company or in
the city you can detect you can know
pacifically why is this
the public don't communicate well with a
garment you can know better what is
wrong which apart is a problem when you
have the insect from the data you can
see oh maybe it's because the garment
never really talked to the people well
so when you diagnose the problem the
very pacific then you can try to use
technology to solve this problem so you
can create a proper tab and you can
mirror the weather this technology it's
this technology can be a website can be
an app can be anything you know
determining our what's a problem you fan
and then you try to use this technology
to commute to connect and you know
enable better communication anything
increase that the positive engagement
posing the piece so that is the part
that you know the next step after you
mayor please what really you can do it's
making a lot more sense to me your
upbringing when you're growing up in
rural with nature and how you also did
all the journalism around technology and
then how it all brings us to this piece
technology you had the initial immersion
in the nature you had buddhist
principles as well you did the
journalism in the tech sector and
entrepreneurship and science and stuff
like that finance and it pieces together
into into this and so I think you're
doing in such incredible work with this
book we I think we should sit down again
at a future time to actually give more
examples of peace technology in
explaining how it is a very successful
in its deployment and also how some of
these new exponential technology fields
how we can potentially recommend
ethicists or philosophers or moral
scientists to enter into those fields
for greater high likelihood of peace
technology where maybe some areas don't
have
peace technology yet we're what examples
could be deployed because people listen
and then they go oh I can build that
peace technology yes this type of stuff
yes actually so I recommend it
there's one piece beauty's database this
is a web set you can you can see all the
all the you know cases examples all what
people already do with peace Ted so it
can this database you would please
database build peace days okay is there
a do we know if there's a build peace
database calm or yes okay okay cool cuz
we'll link that in the bio for everyone
okay yeah and and also I also would like
to recommit piece Innovation Lab at
Stanford and make sure lots of times it
is as far as I know mark Nelson the
director he's the one that and also the
co-founder margarita so z2 are really
are the visionaries you know in use
technology to increase positive peace so
before them like us at peace tech lab
you know there's a lot of like peace
factory they're working on prevent and
competent reduce conflict but in terms
of how to increase ability to be good to
each other there's still lots of
discussion a very big in you know peace
date or what is peace date right how to
define how we can really use technology
to collect and mirrors is saying so this
work I think this Innovation Lab they
did fantastic work and you can simply go
to their website to check yes there'll
be another link in the bio the piece of
Sanford's peace Innovation Lab that's
another big one okay really good really
good
I'm just again I'm just so impressed
with what this is about with what peace
text about with what you guys have put
together I'm very very impressed and I'm
I'm looking forward to what young people
can take and
see the world through this perspective
of peace technology applied to every
field applied to bringing us together
and I'm a huge fan and and I want to
like I said I want to do another episode
where we actually break things down in
deeper I'm give more examples so that
would be a good one yes okay yes Jing
Zhi I'm let's ask you two questions on
the way out okay that we asked on the
show the first question is do you think
we're in a simulation do you yeah do you
think we're in a simulation
oh that's a very interesting question
oh what's the what's your you get out
there let's some people think yes some
people think no some people give some
you know context around why they think
that way some people say maybe because
of this or that well I just like this
beautiful name it's an interesting name
yes and it goes into a lot of different
places with it yeah so I want to ask you
why in the beginning you come up with
name first well it does lead to a lot of
important fields of study for humans a
word like that can lead to a lot of good
studies for humans to understand our
reality that we live in and a lot of
other good things but um and we can talk
more you can maybe since you're
journalists you can maybe sit-down or
three it I can I can unpack this more
for you if you're if you're interested
in it yeah I think it's very interesting
but it's difficult for me to simply to
say yes or no because I feel right it
it's something big and it's much more to
be discussed though yes yes okay good
well we can discuss more than on another
time okay and then what about what he
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world the most beautiful thing in the
world I think
is when when your heart is is literally
you know is I can say maybe happy is not
accurate
happy and peaceful yeah when you are
when you can feel at this moment
your peaceful and your happy I think
that the most beautiful moment that's
the most beautiful thing to have that on
a moment-to-moment basis around the
world of a happy and peaceful state of
living together harmoniously with nature
I mean it's beautiful
thank you Jake sure thank you so much
for coming on the show thank you for
teaching us about your book yeah thank
you thank you sitting pleasure learning
more about you and your life okay
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we would love for
you to check out the links in the bio
below go and check out jinx and neucom
as well as the website as also the
Amazon book link check it out go and
support the book support peace tech go
talk to your friends your families
co-workers people online on social media
about peace tech spread more examples of
peace technology around the world and do
that thing that we mention during the
show take a picture of yourself maybe
with your family with your friends and
say that that you want to ensure you
want to push peace technology around the
world that you want to ensure safety and
no violence around the world things like
that that can really help us make a
better world together and also support
the artists entrepreneurs the scientists
organizations around the world do you
believe and supports simulation all of
our links are below support us on
patreon on paypal on cryptocurrency all
our links are below support us also if
you want to design cool merchandise and
get paid for it that you be linked to
the merchandise is below check that out
and go and build the future everyone
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing thank you very much Ron
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thanks for tuning in we'll see you soon
[Music]
you